the first season of ultimate fight was
really the birth on a um on a you know
uh
a big level for the ufc you know when it
comes to popularity and just coming out
the dark ages of of not knowing who it
was you know not knowing what it was so
being on the second season
uh i felt like i was part of something
at the ground level and uh just being
part of the ufc growing with them has
was been you know a huge experience you
won the second season right yeah and
when were you waiting
when were you the coach
uh season 10 season 10 and the other
coach was rampage
uh and you had brendan schaub on your
team who was on the podcast
recently so quick questions i see
rampage i know you you beat his ass
that guy's got like the scariest looking
face ever like i see that guy i don't
mess with that guy
just quick thoughts on rampage and that
you guys got into it and then also
brennan shop who was on the podcast
thoughts on his career yeah me and
rampage it was a very uh highly uh hot
season you know him and i would go to
the point where um we'll fight every
single day you know to the point where
the production stat was like hey guys i
know you don't like each other but you
know you guys got to find a way to calm
down a little bit because we got to be
able to shoot the scenes and stuff like
that because it was just like the first
time in the history of reality
television the production staff is like
why don't you guys not yes
it was just unruly sometimes you know it
would get it'll get bad and uh you know
the talking though yeah you guys weren't
fighting you guys were no we were
talking smack but it came to a a couple
times where it was almost like we were
gonna fight you know the famous door
scene yeah the famous door scene yeah so
it got pretty contested uh quite a bit
but um
that season was probably uh
the funnest season of the ultimate
fighter and uh you know looking back on
it yeah
wanderluck i can't let you get closer i
mean that was a good one too they
actually fought they actually scrapped
that one but i mean the the one being
rampage it was good because you know it
built up from the ultimate fighter
season then he didn't fight me because
he had that movie with uh um the a-team
and then we end up fighting so it's a
little bit more of a build up to the
actual fight and it will you know it was
it was a good fight you know but now uh
me and rampage we got a chance to uh
actually do a movie together we did a
movie together um called boss level we
played german twins so we kind of got to
a chance to you know speak about what
happened before and you said german
twins german twins
you have a good german accent what are
you going to do
and then what about shaub uh brandon
schaub you know i knew brendan chop back
in the day when he was you know first
starting off with mixed martial arts you
know we would train out in denver with
uh trevor whitman and nate marquart and
those guys you know it was like uh
jackson's gym and then we'll go to
keller
colorado and train at grudge gym and go
to tristar so we would go and train with
brendan chubb when he was first starting
off and uh when i when i found out i was
going to do the ultimate fighter season
you know i really a strong advocate for
getting him and uh getting him into the
show and um you know brendan brennan was
phenomenal man brendan was like you know
a diamond in a rough he just didn't know
how good he was you know he was one of
those guys who um i honestly believe um
had he not
went on a streak where he got caught a
couple times he he could have been
somebody who really done something
really yeah
brendan was good man brendan was good
man he uh
i know he had that tough talk with joe
rogan when joe rogan told him to sit
down but you know it's um
in the heavyweight division you can get
caught and knocked out you know it's
it's very easy for that to happen and at
some point you have to modify your game
you know you have to be able to
understand the fact that you can't sit
there and exchange blows like you can
at a smaller weight class so you have to
be able to be able to use different
tactics i mean you know throwing some
punches and doing a little bit of cage
wall and brawl and kind of just gumming
up the action a little bit more and not
doing so much of the you know standing
at the 50 50 and see who lands first so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you